yes or ii ich kann leider doch nicht ich
muss auf meinen 15-jährigen kleinen
bruder aufpassen
kleiner tipp noch bevor das wieder
losgeht drückt einfach neben den
abonnieren -button auf diese glocke weil
dann verpasst ihr nichts mehr
willkommen beim ein video ich muss heute
wieder etwas leiser reden weil wir haben
mal wieder halb zwei ich weiß ja
überhaupt nicht warum ich ausgerechnet
jetzt wie ein videodreh er gut ich hätte
ja vielleicht auch schon fünf stunden er
machen können aber irgendwie sitze ich
dann da und mach einfach gar nichts die
scheiße sie muss am morgen um acht uhr
aufstehen um 8 uhr war egal viele von
euch hat mir wahrscheinlich das video
gesehen was jungs machen und mädchen
immer falsch verstehen und da hab ich
euch dazu aufgefordert schreibt auch mal
in die kommentare weil ich jetzt auch so
wieder bisschen bockhop organisierung
smideliusz wie früher immer was ich so
noch mal soll in diese richtung und ich
hab da eben einfach mal reingeschaut und
hatten kommentare entdeckt er hatte
irgendwie so 350 likes und da dachte ich
mir so westhoff von easy ich habe
wirklich so 5 punkte oder 10 punkte
runter geschrieben und darüber geht das
video heute besuchen konnte was soll das
katzen ich jetzt einfach anzeigen hier
2000 jahre später ich finde die
kommentar einfach nicht keine ahnung ich
bin einfach mal kurz ein und zwar ging
der irgendwie so mach doch mal ein video
darüber was jungs machen um mädchen zu
zeigen dass sie nichts von ihnen wohl
wenn ich es mir wirklich so einfach
machen wollt dann macht es mir halt so
einfach und ich würde sagen wir fanden
sofort man mit dem logischen punkt
überhaupt und zwar ein ganz klares
anzeichen ist er meldet sich nicht bei
euch ja das wasser auch schon ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen
lasst noch nach oben da schaut drein ok
nich spaß ihr hatte glück ich habe mich
wirklich hingesetzt und noch ein paar
punkte mehr erarbeitet die auch mega
viel sinn ergeben also ok also erster
punkt er meldet sich nicht bei dir
zweite punkt er meldet sich bei dir
allerdings nur wenn er besoffen ist so
ganz klare sache so wenn man sich nicht
bei einer person normalen zustand ist es
ein ganz schlechtes zeichen
aber wenn man besoffen ist und irgendwie
notgeld ist oder sonstwas und sich dann
bei der person meldete bei dir meldet
wenn du dich jetzt wird angesprochen
fühlst und genau deswegen das video
schaut weil du irgendwann hast der
vielleicht ob die stellt vielleicht aber
nicht wenn er sich nur in besonderen
zustand bei gemeldet und sich als
komisches objekt betrachtet dann ist das
falsch weil es gibt einfach so viele
jung ist dem es oft in zustand einfach
so notgeil durch die weltgeschichte
irren und nach irgendwelchen objekten
also in dem zustand dann wirklich von
ihnen angesehene objekte suchen mit
denen sie okay so übertrieben ist es
jetzt auch nicht
kommen wir zum nächsten punkt auch ganz
offensichtlich und zwar wenn sich ein
junger nur bei dir meldet wenn er etwas
von dir möchte aber jetzt halt keine
beziehungen sondern irgendwas du
solltest du gefallen weil du solltest im
zehn euro geben du sollst das und dass
wir ihn erledigen ja also dass solche
aber auch eigentlich jeder für sich
selber checken also wenn ein junger
immer nur auf dich zukommt und
irgendetwas von ihr möchte hier kannst
du das trinken oder york kannst du das
für mich machen und du denkst acht der
macht es bei der auf mich steht dann die
ich so falsch ist aber auch selbst
erklärend ok punkt nummer vier ist
anders und meint auch genauso aber wenn
du dich mit deinem schwarm oder dem
jungen auf den städten treffen uns
gemacht also ihr wolltet treffen geht
ins kino ihr macht das und das und du
freust dich richtig und fünf minuten vor
schreibt er
sorry ich kann leider
ich muss auf meinen 15-jährigen kleinen
bruder aufpassen
dieses beispiel hat die antwort schon
voraus genommen würde ich sagen
15-jähriger kleiner bruder auch nicht so
ganz
er könnte auch einfach schreiben ich hab
kein bock dann kommt einfach zu mir
kommen wir zu punkt nummer fünf ist zwar
mega oberflächlich aber was auch ganz
einfach ihr folgt eurem schwaben die
person auf die ihr steht der junge der
übels geiles für euch neu erfolgt alex
war nicht so gemeint also ihr wisst was
meine er folgt eurem schwarm eurem
jungen den style findet auf instagram
instagram hey ich kann einfach nicht
mehr sprechen dann was ich dir nur ihr
folgt eurem schwarm schrägstrich eurem
lieblings jung schrägstrich alex
schrägstrich nicht erfolgt im jungen auf
denen steht auf instagram oder sonstwo
und erfolgt euch nicht wie schon gesagt
mega oberflächlich aber ist vielleicht
auch ein zeichen dafür dass es nichts
wird euch wird so die social network
sind hat die sind richtig hart das lässt
sich auch als sexistisches arschloch
sein wie du kannst du doch nicht machen
halt die fresse ok fordert zeitpunkt
auch wieder ganz einfach der junge
schreibt mit euch und ihr freut euch so
beschreibt mit mir das ist ja ein gutes
zeichen aber erwähnt die ganze zeit dass
er irgendein anderes mädchen übels geil
findet oder eure deutschlehrerin übels
geil findet oder das und das übels gelb
findet ihr nicht das also schon eher
mädchen andere mädchen er sagt obama die
chance alles übers geil
sag ich ja auch persönlich sehr auch
bald chantal ist einfach geil dann ist
das gar nicht gut mit ok und dann kommen
jetzt auch schon zum letzten punkt und
der letzte punkt da musste ich wirklich
sehr sehr lange hin und her grübeln was
ich denn da ist auch ins video nehmen
kann
und mir das feste kommt immer zum
schluss ein ganz klares anzeichen dass
das mit euch beiden so wahrscheinlich in
der näheren zukunft nichts wird ist ganz
einfach wenn der junge schwule ist weil
dann kann das nichts werden
das waren jetzt sieben oder acht punkte
ich habe keine ahnung und ich hoffe
dieses video hat euch gefallen wenn das
der fall war dann lasst mal daumen nach
oben da ich würde mal sagen bei 10 15000
6 mal das nächste jungs mädchen video
schreibt doch dazu auch einfach mal in
die kommentare was sie als nächstes für
ein junges mädchen video von mir sehen
wollt und las bei dem kommentar oder bei
dem vorschlag der ich am besten gefällt
doch nach oben da dann kann ich das ganz
einfach wieder ermittelt ansonsten ein
schöner und schönen tag wir sehen uns
morgen wieder beim ein video 19 uhr ich
zähle auf euch und das mit dem leise
reden hat heute auch nicht so geklappt
hat rein